my confidence level has sort of lessened
gone down a little bit over the years
sure as I get older and older I don't
know why because when I was young I was
sort of that guy that we talked about
earlier that comes up it's like hey
what's going on yeah yeah hey I don't
care I'm here I'm gonna make it I'm a
star yes and then something it's still
that I could I could approachable I'm
but something uh
I don't know if I just got tired of it
or if I just got
I don't know what it is I think I know
what you're saying because and I think
my answer is yes
um I think my arrogant confidence has
diminished significantly and that's not
to poo poo that I think arrogant
confidence is necessary to handle the
rejection which is where you started
yeah to go like no I'm great no I'll do
it fine oh you know I could I could do
it better I'm the best one for that
some of that to do what we do yeah there
does like you're just in nature in the
nature of entertainment the
entertainment business of show
everybody who participates
somewhere in some way and however they
Define it for themselves as like
I'm worth looking at yeah I mean like
yeah I'm worth listening to so the air
like the
similarly like certainly through my 20s
into my early 30s the idea of like I
know how to do it best yep that has gone
away of now it's I know how to do it how
I like might not be the right way might
not be the most popular way but where I
have gained is just sort of like like
the earned confidence of repetition
right of just like yeah I've put in the
Reps I've put in the time I've I know
what it takes to do that and it allows
me to
it allows me to kind of like
not get too upset about rejection but
also to maybe not put myself out there
where I would before yeah which I think
there's a downside to that because I'm
certain that many jobs I went out for in
my early career I was like like Mad TV
is a great example like I'm not gonna
get this I don't deserve and it worked
or you meet the casting director goes I
love you not this thing but the next
thing I bring you in you know that
happened a lot for me and now I'm just
like I have to drive where yeah isn't
that something yeah you know I wrote
this down while you were talking I was
listening yes but something I will
forget things I drew a picture of you
and I want to share it with the audience
um no it is uh
it's it's the difference between
rejection accepting rejection being good
at rejection and being good at failure
and that that came up because I thought
no one I'm not going to say no one but I
am really great at when someone says no
I mean hurts a little bit like if a girl
doesn't want to go out with me a second
time I'm like we had a great date I need
to know why what happened yeah I don't
get crazy I just kind of feel bad yeah
I'm like ah that kind of sucks it
happened yeah uh not that long ago um
but
but I could deal with rejection when
someone says uh I don't get a call back
or I don't get the part I let it go I
forget about it yeah my mother doesn't
that's why I don't tell her anything
what happened to Private Ryan
it was 30 years ago
over
but but here's the difference
failure hurts a little more
because I you know when I do something
and I put my heart into it and I feel
like I've done the best I could and I
think I'm pretty good and I think
everybody's good and and then it airs
and then it gets canceled after a couple
of Seasons I think it's not that it
I don't it just feels like ah that was
on me that was on me so maybe they maybe
they don't want to see me as much I wish
I wish to let that go I wish for you you
dealt with failure you had to show
recently so much single uh single
parents two seasons two seasons gone
yeah
yeah people an audience didn't connect
and it could be a million things it
could be a million things and it could
be me but
the friendships the friendships the uh
the
um income the the stability the
structure the shooting in town like you
said the doing a job with people I
really liked like across the board and
it feeling like reasonable hours like
there's so much thank goodness for those
two years and you also learn like what
about that scenario would I want to
recreate what would I not want to and
how do I
you know use that to make choices moving
forward I mean I I do hear what you're
saying and I'm I if I'm being completely
honest probably have felt similarly at
times but
I'm at a place now like with my children
where I'm encouraging failure as much as
possible right because the oh God yeah
the the idea to do it right right away
or the idea to be good at it right away
or I'm not into it
I want my daughters to have exposure and
have access to as many passion skills uh
subjects as possible but to understand
it will take time effort putting in reps
putting in the hours to get better at it
then nobody starts
perfect right no and and perfect is not
a non-existent thing anyway but nobody
starts as a master of something you have
to earn that and you there's no I I
bet um I'm a certain I'm 100 confident
no one became a master without ever
failing once I I agree and probably the
Masters failed more than anybody else
and just didn't let the idea that it was
them get in their way I think it took me
a long time
I think I was lucky in the sense that
I started acting and immediately I was
funny and people liked me and I started
getting cast and everything and and but
and things just took off yeah and after
we got that retainer after we got that
yeah yeah you know it's funny because I
remember my manager that day on on set
he goes hey I really think you should
fix your teeth I go whoa
what he goes listen it's it's character
it's fine uh you're a good looking guy
your teeth are crooked and I think if
you straighten them out you get leading
roles so I said [__] it put on a
retainer six months later I started
getting lead roles boom it worked